[Musica]
victoria hall boyle hub di dio tracy e
vojvodina chi sono cosa fanno
qual è la loro storia
cosa vi viene in mente quando sentite
per la prima volta i loro nomi
vi do un piccolissimo inizio anno tutti
una cosa in comune hanno la pelle nera o
meglio i loro genitori sono immigrati
dall'africa e allora sono nati e
cresciuti qui in italia e il nome frutto
spesso estremamente radicato a quella
che la nostra identità ma è qualcosa che
diamo troppo poco per scontato il nome è
qualcosa che che probabilmente facciamo
anche fatica a pronunciare ma abbiamo
imparato a dire schopenhauer non
dovrebbe essere un problema ma occore
bojo ed io ho
il mio discorso stasera e che vorrei
portarvi a scoprire cosa si nasconde
dietro le storie dei corpi invisibile o
concetto di invisibilità che in realtà
ho scoperto ed ho imparato a scoprire
facendo una panoramica su quelli che
erano i corpi dei migranti già
dall'epoca di mia madre di mia madre si
intende già da 20 30 anni fa e di come
la storia di mia madre è di quelli e
quelle poi mia madre ancora oggi si
rispecchia sui loro figli sulle nostre
identità sulla nostra storia e non ci dà
una narrazione che sia solo ed
esclusivamente nostra ma che diventa
sempre uno specchio ed un riflesso di
quelle che sono le categorie in cui
l'oro prima sono stati inseriti nelle
categorie prestabilite che non avevano
via d'uscita delle categorie molto
spesso brutalmente orribile o
semplicemente molto umile nelle
categorie che potevano essere magari dei
lavori come quello del bracciante
corrado da delle pulizie
o come lo spacciatore o come la
prostituta perché perché siamo abituati
a vedere il nostro immaginario quelle
persone che fanno solo ed esclusivamente
quel lavoro che non possono fuoriuscire
da con gli schemi e se lo fanno
rimangono probabilmente sempre
invisibili l'invisibilità di cui vi
parlo e ogni visibilità soprattutto a
livello lavorativo ogni visibilità che
vede corpi di uomini neri morti sui
campi sotto il sole
probabilmente anche sottopagati
ma che viene completamente passato per
indifferente agli occhi dello stato in
visibilità di cui vi parlo e le
disabilità di cui e stata vittima mia
madre per tantissimi anni una ragazza
che parte della nigeria quando il sogno
magari anche abbastanza condiviso di
privare il nostro paese di poter
lavorare studiare cambiare completamente
prospettiva in vita e di poter aiutare
quelle che la sua donna di anni nigeria
mia madre però viene convinta da una
donna che mi piace definire vestita di
illusioni e arriva in italia il 18 19
anni e si ritrova a lavorare superstrada
e la vita mia madre cambia completamente
la narrazione che si ha avuto del corpo
di mia madre che è stata vittima della
tratta della prostituzione delle donne
nigeriane sulle strade italiane
purtroppo si riflette ancora tutte
quelle che sono donne e soprattutto
donne nere qui in italia ed è quasi
difficile pensare che possa esserci
un'altra 4 tipo di linguaggio un'altra
tipo di narrazione è un'altra etichetta
ma che semplicemente quelle etichette si
mettano completamente di esistere io
oggi
vorrei provare a cambiare l'idea che
possa esserci o meno un etichetta a far
sì che i corpi che per molto tempo sono
stati invisibili prendano finalmente
un riconoscimento una riappropriazione
di se stessi
soprattutto quando si parla di
riconoscimenti in termini legali in
termini documenti in termini che pochi
giorni fa a torino è scoppiata la
notizia di donne e sono state costrette
un minacciate che alla quale avrebbero
lasciato il permesso di soggiorno sono
in cambio di prestazioni sessuali
e in questo caso il permesso di
soggiorno che molto spesso viene
definito auto come la cittadinanza sono
semplice pezzo di carta ti rende
ricattabile perché la tua vita diventa
ricattabile perché a che fare con quella
che la tua salute ha a che fare con
quello che il tuo lavoro a che fare con
quello che il futuro dei tuoi figli
figlie che anche se nasceranno in italia
non avranno comunque la speranza
italiana ma saranno costretti a
richiederla 18 anni nel mio caso
fortunatamente l'ho ottenuta 19 anni ma
in altri casi come di persone che
conosco l'hanno ottenuta dopo nove o
dieci anni e questo cosa significa
significa che non puoi votare significa
che non puoi partecipare ai concorsi
pubblici che non puoi viaggiare alcune
parti del mondo significa che viene
completamente dimenticato è vestito di
un mantello dell'invisibilità che
purtroppo ci rende oscuro e l'invisibile
agli occhi dello stato agli occhi dello
stato per quanto riguarda ovviamente una
cosa prettamente legale per quanto
riguarda invece quella che la tua
identità quelli che sono i tuoi sogni
quella che è la tua passione
quello che sei tu
perché il colore della tua pelle
il tuo nome molto spesso difficile da
pronunciare viene sempre prima e so che
effettivamente 6 quando vi fatto i primi
tre nomi all'inizio molto probabilmente
anche per un brindisi modì secondo
avrete pensato
a dove inserire queste tre persone come
lo dico io
abdou diouf è il primo biologo e nero
italiano di origine senegalese
teresi è la prima donna che era di
origini nigeriane a vincere masterchef
italia e victoria è la prima donna nera
a candidarsi al consiglio comunale di
parma e stiamo partita o un biologo
si era comunale è semplicemente
masterchef italia per dire che nella
narrazione che vogliamo dei nostri corpi
di questa fantomatica seconda
generazione
apre discendenti affari italiani è una
narrazione è umile e semplice che non ha
più nulla a che fare con quello che
hanno fatto o che sono stati i nostri
genitori ma con quello che possiamo fare
noi e con quello che possiamo essere
effettivamente noi a prescindere a
prescindere la mio cognome che sia i
fiorai gli stimoli bojo o che sia di of
a prescindere dalla mia terra straniera
o che sia bianca purtroppo però abbiamo
un grandissimo privilegio o meglio molti
di voi piano o grandissimo privilegio
che quello del nome prettamente italiano
che sono come italiano e della bella è
che quella bianca
infatti in conclusione vi inviterei si
viva a fare un piccolissimo esperimento
insieme a me ad alzare un braccio con il
palmo della mano aperto se lo usate
insieme un invito a scoprire cos'è
questo privilegio abbassati un dietro
ogni volta che leggo qualcosa che ha che
fare strettamente con la borsa con la
vostra persona o che un'esperienza che
avete vissuto sulla nostra pelle
abbassa un dito se ci sei mai sentito
oggetto discriminazione quando entrambi
in una stanza tutti gli occhi erano
rivolti verso di te se che hanno
guardato e che hanno detto torna del tuo
paese come se il tuo paese non fosse
questo in cui se l'ato
abbassano lieto se non riesci a trovare
casa o il lavoro non riesce a trovare
casa perché a quelli copertino affittano
perché non pagano e non riesce a trovare
un lavoro o soprattutto a stretto
contatto con il pubblico perché i
clienti potrebbero essere spaventati o a
disagio essere serviti da una commedia
abbasso indietro se ogni volta che sia
passato di fronte alle forze dell'ordine
hai sentito il cuore 3 mario mille e che
quando ti hanno chiesto di esibire i
documenti che hanno chiesto sempre e
solo il permesso di soggiorno perché se
sei qui in italia o se un irregolare poi
un permesso di soggiorno
la carta d'identità intendo chiesta mai
basta un dietro
se c'è stata lo stato oggetto delle
fantasie degli altri fantasie sessuali
che ti hanno visto semplicemente come
qualcosa di esotico come è una fantasia
selvaggia qualcosa di esaudire abbassa
un dietro se sei stanco che il tuo nome
e la tua pelle venga sempre prima di
quella che è la tua storia di quello che
sei e se sei pronto ad un cambiamento in
un linguaggio diverso
se siete rimasti con il palo coperto
quello il nostro privilegio bianco e no
non è una colpa ma lo diventerà nel
momento in cui ignorerete cioè che
succede al ragazzo la ragazza col pugno
chiuso al vostro fianco
grazie
[Applauso]